[Musique]
merci
on nous a menti
je vois déjà les gens dans la première
rangée qui me regardent et qui se disent
et le Québécois
tu as vraiment fait 6 heures de vol pour
venir nous rejoindre en Alsace à ce TDX
dont la thématique cette année de
réenchanter le monde tu as vraiment
traversé l'Atlantique
pour venir nous dire qu'on nous a menti
et ben oui
oui
parce qu'on nous a menti on nous a menti
la toute première fois qu'on nous le dit
et depuis dans 90% des bouquins des
conférences en développement personnel
on nous a menti
quand on nous a dit qu'on pouvait
changer le monde pour le réenchanter
et ça moi j'y ai cru
d'une grande vérité universelle j'y ai
cru à un point tel où j'ai pris la
décision consciente de complètement
mettre de côté une société que j'avais
fondée plusieurs années auparavant qui
était profitable qui embaucher des gens
me sentant investi par cette mission moi
aussi d'aller changer le monde pour le
réenchanter je montais sur des scènes
comme celle-ci avec mes souliers bien
cirés mon habit bien pressé mon sourire
permanent mes cheveux gris de grand sage
mon PowerPoint très Glé à la seconde
près dans des salles ma foi comme
celle-ci où on tamisait les lumières et
on servait une bonne tisane bien chaude
de queue de castor séché du Canada
à tous les participants tout en faisant
jouer comme musique de fond les plus
grands succès de Yanni à la flûte de Pan
jusqu'au jour où mon meilleur ami au
Québec marque qui assistait ma
conférence pour la toute première fois
et au risque de notre amitié
jusqu'au jour où Marc m'a regardé dans
les yeux mais du genre
cette mission tu t'es donnée d'aller
changer le monde pour le réenchanter à
travers la conférence à laquelle je
viens de citer
c'est de la merde
vous trouvez ça drôle mais moi
c'est un choc qui m'a mis KO pendant 6
mois
6 mois d'arrêt complet au niveau
professionnel six mois où j'ai eu à
revoir complètement mon approche mon
discours comme conférencier en
développement personnel et six mois au
bout desquels j'ai finalement compris
qu'effectivement on m'avait menti en me
laissant croire que moi je pouvais
changer le monde que moi je pouvais
réenchanter le monde
et aujourd'hui j'aimerais partager avec
vous les trois principales choses que
j'ai comprises de ce mensonge la
première c'est que je peux pas changer
le monde puis je peux pas réenchanter le
monde non plus et je vais vous dire
pourquoi la deuxième c'est que changer
pour réenchanter mon monde c'est
possible c'est même simple
mais il y a personne qui m'a promis que
ce serait facile et je vais vous dire
pourquoi
et enfin ce que j'ai compris de ce
mensonge bah c'est comment changer pour
réenchanter mon monde à moi et pour moi
ça passe à travers le guide de trois
vérités que je vais partager avec vous
aujourd'hui
donc commençons par cette idée de
présumer pouvoir changer le monde pour
le réenchanter
et ben on peut pas
on peut juste on peut pas espérer que
par magie ou par cette grande force de
l'univers que les gens deviennent
enchantés ou réenchanter on peut juste
et ça moi ben je l'ai appris plus
souvent qu'autrement à la dure parce
qu'à travers cette mission que je
m'étais donné je pensais être capable
moi de changer les gens pour les rendre
plus heureux plus comblés plus
satisfaits satisfaite plus enchantée
pensez changer la vie de
mes amis mes conjointes les membres de
ma famille les gens qui assistaient à
mes conférences maintenant je suis
convaincu que certaines peut-être
plusieurs de ces personnes
ont changé pour réenchanter leur vie
mais justement
c'est eux qui l'ont fait
pas moi
donc la toute première chose que j'ai
compris de ce mensonge c'est que je peux
pas moi réenchanter je peux pas changer
le monde pour le réenchanter et n'allez
pas croire que vous le pouvez
le seul monde qu'on peut changer le seul
monde qu'on peut réenchanter c'est le
nôtre
changer nous avant tout
réenchanter nous avant tout
c'est simplement
mais est-ce que c'est facile
ben non c'est pas facile non il y a eu
il y a il y aura des obstacles dans ce
processus à votre réenchantement à notre
réenchantement je partage avec vous
trois des principaux obstacles qui selon
moi fige la majorité d'entre nous dans
le réenchantement de notre vie le
premier
la stupidité
la stupidité c'est de savoir quoi faire
savoir quoi faire pour changer savoir
quoi faire pour réenchanter notre monde
on le sait mais on le fait pas
pire on fait trop souvent le contraire
premier obstacle deuxième obstacle à
notre réenchantement à nous avant tout
la paresse
vous avez sûrement déjà entendu sur des
scènes comme celle-ci ou lu dans un
bouquin c'est grand maître à penser
qu'il nous disent que la connaissance
est le pouvoir
ben non
mais non c'est pas la connaissance qui
est le pouvoir c'est ce qu'on fait de la
connaissance parce que bien installé sur
votre canapé paresseux paresseux à
passer vos journées à regarder les
mouches voler
sans ne rien faire de votre connaissance
ne changera pas votre vie ne
réenchantera pas votre vie
deuxième obstacle apparaisse maintenant
je vais comprendre et vous pardonner si
vous trébuchez peut-être même plus d'une
fois il y a une limite mais peut-être
plus d'une fois dans ces deux premiers
obstacles parce que je suis moi-même
couramment stupide
selon la définition que j'ai dit et
parfois paresseux
mais ce troisième obstacle qui fige
beaucoup trop de gens
pour vous là les autres
troisième obstacle qui fige beaucoup
trop de gens dans le réenchantement de
leur vie et ben c'est de s'en
tout simplement
de se complaire dans le statut quad
désenchanté de la vie qu'ils ont
actuellement prendre la décision
consciente de ne pas faire plus avoir
plus et être plus et ça pour moi dans
une vie qui nous a été donnée c'est
inacceptable impardonnable
et ce qui est phénoménal de constater
c'est que nous sommes nous l'être humain
l'être supérieur nous sommes la seule
espèce vivante sur terre
à se contenter à se contenter de ce
qu'on est de ce qu'on fait de ce qu'on a
seul espèce vivante vous avez déjà vu
vous un arbre rendu à un mètre
sans contenter
ne plus produire de fruits ne plus
perdre ses feuilles à l'automne pour les
voir rejaillir au printemps ben non mais
non l'arbre en santé
et je pourrais vous donner une foule
d'autres exemples donc je sais pas pour
vous mais moi j'en ai marre au Québec on
dit je suis tannique
j'en ai marre de ce discours calinours
qui nous est répété depuis des années à
savoir que c'est facile changer entre
autres pour réenchanter notre vie que
c'est facile ben non c'est pas facile
on rencontre tous des obstacles c'est
simple mais il y a pas personne qui nous
a promis que ce serait facile et c'est
la deuxième chose que j'ai compris de ce
mensonge
maintenant comment changer pour
réenchanter notre vie troisième chose
que j'ai comprises de ce mensonge et ben
pour moi ça passe à travers le guide de
trois vérités trois vérités que je
partage avec vous aujourd'hui va y aller
comme une boussole comme un GPS
réfléchissez à ces trois vérités là
peut-être les mettre en pratique si vous
le voulez bien et voyez où ça vous
mènera sur le chemin de votre
réenchantement à vous
première vérité qui me guide moi dans le
réenchantement de ma vie c'est de
comprendre et d'accepter que ma vie est
de ma faute votre vie est de votre faute
on parle ici de prendre l'entière
responsabilité de notre vie et bien sûr
qu'il y a des exceptions mais je parle
pas aux exceptions je parle à la masse
et le mot faute que les gens aient
tellement le mot faute il faut bien
comprendre que ce n'est rien d'autre
que les conséquences positives ou
négatives pas uniquement négative comme
on relit ça habituellement homophobe
positive ou négative de nos pensées nos
paroles et nos actions prendre la
responsabilité de notre vie prendre la
responsabilité de notre réenchantement
est à mes yeux le geste le plus
libérateur et le plus transformateur qui
soit
deuxième vérité qui me guide moi dans le
réenchantement de ma vie ça repose sur
le principe d'abandon abandonné parce
que vous deviendrez pas heureux comme
par miracle grâce à l'univers vous
deviendrez pas heureux vous deviendrez
pas vous devrez avant tout abandonner
ce qui vous rend malheureux
vous deviendrez pas riche vous devrez
avant tout abandonner ce qui vous rend
et maintient pauvre sans le sou vous
deviendrez pas mince vous devrez avant
tout abandonner ce qui vous rend et
maintient
grâce à
grassouillette
vous deviendrez pas enchanté ou
réenchanter comme par magie vous devrez
avant tout abandonner ce qui vous
maintient dans le statu quo de votre vie
désenchantée actuelle
maintenant
la troisième vérité là je dois vous
mettre en garde
l'expression que je m'apprête à utiliser
est une expression politiquement
incorrecte
mais c'est une expression que j'utilise
couramment au Québec et on m'a donné la
permission de l'utiliser avec vous
aujourd'hui
soyez avertis
donc cette troisième vérité qui me guide
dans le réenchantement de ma vie ben
c'est d'habiter mes couilles
je vous avais averti
maintenant il faut comprendre ceci avoir
des couilles n'a rien à voir avec ce qui
se passe ou pas
entre nos deux cuisses
avoir des couilles ça se passe entre les
deux oreilles c'est un état d'esprit une
façon de vivre une philosophie de vie et
mesdames ne vous offusquez pas de cette
expression parce que je connais bien des
femmes
bien des femmes qui ont pas mal plus de
couilles que d'hommes
maintenant habiter ses couilles et ben
c'est de définir avec précision avec
clarté
ces valeurs et ses croyances pour
lesquelles on se tiennent bout
qui vont dans le sens de ce qu'on veut
faire de notre vie
définir avec clarté nos valeurs et les
respecter et les faire respecter sans
compromis malgré les critiques parce que
les gens vous critiqueront pour cette
clarté mais le jour où ça arrivera parce
que ça arrivera
posez-vous la question suivante c'est la
vie des gens
des critiques que vous voulez changer ou
la vôtre
si la vie des critiques que vous voulez
réenchanter
ou la vôtre
habiter vos couilles
dans le respect de ces valeurs et de ses
croyances que vous aurez définies avec
clarté
merci
alors voilà
voilà ce que j'ai compris les trois
principales choses que j'ai comprises de
ce message et elle est là la vraie
raison pour le pardon je suis en train
de reculer elle est là la vraie raison
pour laquelle j'ai traversé l'Atlantique
pour venir vous voir aujourd'hui et
partager ce point de vue et vous y faire
réfléchir mais au-delà d'y réfléchir
tout ce discours aujourd'hui de ma part
ne servira absolument à rien
si vous n'en faites rien
c'est pourquoi j'ai pensé vous proposer
un petit exercice à faire dans les
prochaines 24 heures quand vous
retournez à la maison vous sortez papier
et crayon je présume que ça existe
encore sur du papier et des crayons
papier et crayon dans le haut de votre
feuille vous écrivez votre nom tout
juste en dessous vous écrivez mon
réenchantement et de ma faute vous en
prenez la responsabilité et vous divisez
cette feuille en trois colonnes dans la
toute première colonne à l'extrême
gauche vous rédigez avec votre crayon
sur le papier je sais que c'est une
habituel mais tenter de le faire
vous rédigez la photo de votre vie
actuelle dans toutes les sphères de
votre vie ce que vous faites ce que vous
avez ce que vous êtes plus précisément
possible deuxième colonne celle du
centre vous faites exactement le même
exercice mais tourner vers l'avenir ce
que vous voulez faire ce que vous voulez
être et avoir pour le reste de votre vie
la vie à laquelle vous aspirez
habituellement dans les deux premières
colonnes ça va assez bien l'eau ça se
corse un petit peu c'est un petit peu
plus difficile c'est quand vous arrivez
dans la troisième colonne parce que dans
celle-ci vous devrez définir avec clarté
ce que vous êtes prêt ou prête à
abandonner on vient de parler d'abandon
abandonner de la première colonne
abandonnée de votre vie actuelle pour
faire de la place
à la vie à laquelle vous aspirez ce que
vous voudrez faire avoir et être
une fois ces trois colonnes remplis vous
écrivez dans le bas j'habite mes
couilles
vous signez cette feuille vous inscrivez
la date et vous en prenez une photo un
cliché que vous allez envoyer à votre
meilleur ami votre marque à vous
souhaitant que cette personne aura la
même bienveillance lucidité de partager
avec vous peut-être au risque de votre
amitié partagez avec vous ce qu'elle
pense vraiment son opinion son point de
vue peut-être un jugement sur ce nouveau
plan de match que vous vous êtes donné
pour réenchanter
votre vie
vous savez au Québec on me reconnaît
comme le conférencier
avec la plus courte conférence de
motivation
mais aussi la plus percutante et j'ai
décidé de vous la présenter cette
conférence aujourd'hui
ne clignez pas des yeux ça valait assez
vite
vous pouvez la prendre en note voici ma
conférence de motivation
vous allez mourir
maintenant
maintenant ce qui est important de voir
ces quand vous allez mourir le plus tard
possible quand vous allez mourir est-ce
que vous aurez vous aussi comme beaucoup
trop de monde quand ils arrivent à leur
dernier souffle est-ce que vous aurez
vous aussi se regretter
de ne pas avoir vécu votre vie
comme vous l'entendiez dans le respect
de vos valeurs et de vos croyances comme
vous l'entendiez au lieu de vivre la vie
que les autres voulaient que vous viviez
et moi je pense que de changer avant
tout notre monde de réenchanter avant
tout notre monde nous éloigne de ce
regret potentiel à la fin de notre vie
et je me dis que
si on arrive tous individuellement si on
arrive tous et tout à réenchanter notre
vie avant tout
peut-être
allons-nous en effet contribuer à faire
de cette société et de la société qu'on
laissera derrière nous une société un
peu plus enchantée
merci beaucoup merci